when i was about nine
or ten years old because it would have
happened in the early summer
in between fourth and fifth grade for me
or fifth and sixth grade for me
we went on a boating trip with two other
families
and this is a really big deal for us
so i should tell you about our boat to
begin with so when i was a kid before
my my dad died i was 11
when he died we we had a boat
and i'm not even sure quite precisely
when we got it i might have been in
second grade or
third grade but that was like a really
big deal he had saved
for quite a long time he had a good job
at that time
he was working as a tax attorney he had
gone to law school he had a cpa
and so you know we were sort of climbing
into
um you know solidly middle class and
even upper middle class territory
and so he could afford it to buy a boat
and you know it wasn't a huge thing
it was an 18-foot tri-haul
and we used it for water skiing
and going out on lake nagawica and
sometimes pewaukee lake and
and we did a lot of river trips as well
we did camping with it
we used it a lot for fishing sometimes
we'd go to like
other other lakes as well like you know
lake neban
there's upper and lower i remember being
out there
and you know we're fortunate in that
where we grew up we had lots and lots of
bodies of water
and so boating with with that particular
boat we called it the green arrow
because it was a green tri-haul
that became a major part of our our life
you know i think it the way it is for
many people
who have boats once you've got one
you've got to find you know ways to use
it and there's a lot of upkeep that
you've got to do as well
you know so so there's all sorts of
stories to tell about that
including the story that i'll tell some
time about how i caught
a white bass that almost broke the
wisconsin state record
in that same boat on lake nagawicka with
my dad
so in any case there were a couple other
families from my elementary school there
were the griffins
and i think it was dick and
and gloria maybe he she was a teacher
she
actually taught at our elementary school
and he was like i think a high school
uh gym teacher and football coach he
used to shove himself into this tiny
little chevette
because there was the 1970s and everyone
was trying to save
you know gas he crammed his like six
foot four frame
into that tiny little sub-compact car
and they were pretty cool people and
they had a kid named guy
and he was in my class and then there
were the belmonts
and i remember there was rich he was in
my class
and then it might have been mike and i
don't remember the parents names but in
any case
they had boats so the griffins had a
boat
more of like what we nowadays recognize
as a bass boat
and the belmonts had a boat as well so
my my mom and dad knew these people and
we'd talk
you know a lot and so one day they
hatched the idea
why not go for a trip on the mississippi
and you know the mississippi is a major
river here
in the united states there's all sorts
of you know fables about it and
cool stuff and we'd done some river
trips before where we would go
camping you know on the fox river and
i'm trying to remember
where else we went in wisconsin and what
you do basically is you you
you know you put your boat in at one
place
and then you know somebody brings the
the
car and the trailer down to the place
where you're going to go and you boat
down
and you stop and you know camp out
cook out fish do do all the sort swim
all the sort of things that you want to
do
and very often we would go on these
trips with with other
people i'm not sure quite how my parents
you know
knew or connected with or vetted these
people but
you know we always had a good time i'd
often bring books with me
i remember actually on the river trips
of the mississippi
that's where i first read through
uh the carl edward wagner
kane set of of novellas that were called
death angel
shadow so i remember that in in
particular
so in any case the mississippi is not
a river that runs close to where we were
living on the border of delafield and
wales
so this entailed quite a long trip and
we went out to la crosse which is a you
know small
city university town in
western wisconsin right across the the
river right across the mississippi is
minnesota so we
you know i'm assuming that we left our
our you know
cars and trucks and stations we had a
station wagon at the time
and boat trailers there and
i remember one really cool incident
before we actually got underway
and that was um you know there's
massive barges that go up and down the
mississippi so you know we we all
we must have drove out there like on
probably a weekend or something it was
early summer and we stayed everybody
in in a motel and i remember i think
there was a pool
and you know me and these other boys we
all
we we're all friends and we all hung out
and had a good time together
and my sister i think was kind of you
know she was the only girl on the trip
so she was kind of the
you know the odd woman out you could say
but she got along with a
rich's brother who was like her age as
well
and in any case so we you know stayed
there got up the next morning you know
beautiful morning
uh in in june and uh you know had
breakfast
at some local restaurant and then we're
out
by the mississippi and here comes a big
old barge
and it's got in massive letters along
its side uh gloria g
and so gloria griffin we're like take a
look at that
you know and and i think everybody took
it as kind of an auspicious sign
and it was it was it was pretty good um
and then we we got our boats in in the
water and we had all sorts of food along
and all sorts of things packed up
including tents
and we got underway and we went
south you know following the river which
flows south
and each day
if i remember right you know i think we
may have actually stayed on
on a couple locations multiple
nights but generally what we do is we
we'd you know motor around for a while
and this little
uh not not armada obviously
uh a little convoy right i was thinking
to say caravan but caravan would be for
land stuff there's a little convoy
of three you know pretty small boats
i think the belmonts boat was um you
know about the same size as ours
uh you could probably fit maybe six or
seven people in at tops
and you know and these were boats that
didn't have like cabins or anything
either they ever
everything's exposed to the the elements
basically unless you put the top on it
which is basically just like
you know what you have on a convertible
and so if it was going to rain or
something
you know if it was going to rain hard
you're kind of screwed
or if it's really cold there's no like
heater or anything in the boat
and then we had the other boat and i
remember for some reason
i think maybe we're trying to save gas
we had the
other smaller boat tied behind our boat
we were towing it
with the um the water skiing
like rope or whatever we call that that
sort of thing
and you know we had all sorts of like
inner tubes and
air mattresses along as well and so we
you know we
tooled you know maybe a couple hours i
don't know maybe longer
and then we pulled in by a sandbar and
there were all these
massive sand bars some of which exist
for years and years some of which
disappear some of which shift around
the mississippi like most uh major
rivers
is constantly changing its face
sometimes it'll like change its course
significantly this has happened in the
past and so
um you know we we camped out we set up
the tents and then
you know they had like a grill along and
um they were cooking various things i
think they also had a lot of beer and
liquor
quite frankly as well and i know we had
quite a bit of soda
uh and and water too and so we would
like camp out there and then we would
just do stuff
you know like we had frisbees we played
tag
um we went fishing swimming
you know we found all sorts of clams
that we dug up and then our parents
didn't want to
go through the work of you know uh
actually like harvesting them so they
told us to put them back
because they they had enough of food
along they didn't want things that were
high maintenance
or high work and um we had was a great
time i mean
there were some problems my sister got
sunburned i got sunburned a bit you know
but
then it would it would fade after a
while
the belmonts were were darker so they
didn't have so much trouble with that i
the guy was pretty pretty
uh pale too so he got sunburned
and um i just remember it being you know
very
fun trip and
we never really wanted for anything
there were a few times when the weather
got bad but for the most part it was
this beautiful
sky it wasn't too hot you know there
were some times where
um you'd run into like a lot of
mosquitoes and start getting bitten up
quite a bit
but you know overall it wasn't too bad
and some of the sand dunes that we
were well not that sand dunes some of
the sand bars the islands that we
we stayed on must have been pretty
permanent because some of them had like
you know
woods on them and and you know there
would be fireflies at night
in some places and yeah it was it was a
great time and i think if i remember
right the adults
took the boats and like went to nearby
towns to get more supplies from time to
time
but there was always some adult out
there with us watching us and we had to
be careful you know because
it was a river with a significant
current so we were all lectured on like
you know don't go too
far out there are some you know decent
sized fish
in these water um you know keep an eye
out for what's going on
watch out for other boats that are that
are going down the river
um and we did this for about a week
and it was it was a really nice
trip it was a good time with my mom and
dad
i had no idea that we weren't going to
have my dad with us for
for that much longer and i'm really glad
that you know one of the things that
i'll say about him he worked very hard
a lot of long hours and
but he spent a lot of time with us kids
and a lot of that time
was involving the boat and we did things
as a family and we did things with other
families as well so
it was a really excellent trip um
you know we i'm not even sure how far
down we went
i think we went pretty close to where
wisconsin ends and iowa begins
you know um we're in the river that that
entire time
and um beautiful skies at night
you know there were a few rainstorms
here and there but for the most part it
was you know fairly
clear skies you could see so many stars
out there and there was this constant
sound
of the waves and the river and the
current and all of that
so that was uh that was a memory
you know i haven't thought about that
for for quite a while in in the sort of
depth that i'm going into here
but it's kind of nice to bring it up
because um
there were so many other trips that we
took so many other
camping trips sometimes with a boat
sometimes not
you know but that was one that that
really stuck in my my mind and then you
know we
got done and drove back uh i guess you
could call that a caravan or
three three uh i think there was a truck
involved i know we had a station wagon
you know driving these boats back to to
the area that we were from i think if i
remember right the belmonts were from
uh maybe delafield or genesee depot
and i think uh the griffins were from
genesee depot as well we lived on the
border
of delafield and wales which none of
this will mean anything to you unless
you know
local geography in uh you know western
waukesha county
and wisconsin but suffice it to say you
know
we we went out there as a group
i don't remember there being any any
real
like fights or squabbles or anything
like that
and we just really enjoyed ourselves and
it was a great
start to that that summer uh you know
we did a lot of other things that summer
as well and again i'm not even sure
whether it was the summer after i'd
finished fifth grade
which would have been kind of
significant because if it was
that would have been the the very last
summer that we had my dad
with us um the summer after that the
summer of
sixth to seventh grade uh he was dying
in the hospital
including in in rochester minnesota
and i would have been transitioning as
well
away from the public school system to go
to university lake school so i would
have been leaving my
my friends behind going into a totally
new school where basically you were
either smart or rich and there wasn't a
lot of overlap between the two
uh if it was fourth grade to fifth grade
then we were all at wales elementary and
going
we were becoming the big kids at wales
elementary because it only went up to
to fifth grade but i'm not even sure
which it was
in any case i thought i'd share that
that interesting
little story with you about the trip
down the
a portion of the mississippi in the
middle
of a summer which would have been either
the summer of 79
or the summer of 1980.
you